so welcome let's talk about what tons of
me services that don't share any date a
and a and you that pears it because i
strongly believe they couldn't
with what small or microsoft is one in the
the narrow interfering this is a typo
microsoft and  hold period this will
try to discus de should definitely be
room for questions
zo especialy en die rent zo
let's get started my name is dennis van
de stilt he became the part i you the
software and be my company that image and
service my
bij de jong  and it well built and
service bus wanna talk about my
processes and perhaps an dokker is wel
and maybe van containers
pias especialidades containers they are
perfectly online zou and other people at
he goosey die
that probably think this is a real great
xap dat de granules aren  it really well
a sterile gilbert he fremont
basically lars containers en till they
go dong punt fortunately ron talk about
the wise en de hou with first name to
the bottom lidl bad bit about history
fact  e becomes motionless this card of
computer is he here's some people
saying is that of the de memories whether
he would come because of her wim bos people
stretchy well he is
so boring or
on the memory sorry just machines
could by sixty  -four hi myself as more of
a bucket bag of sky
there are now some noah to take sex is now
high actions to ignition it's here
ilove msx and he was basically the
competition to bowl by sexy for this
was my first computer in the and
that floppy drive in
the dough i put player the right to 3
cord and play store app mostly software
programs and the cartridge and the first
finger ipad and or you sled a thousand work
for some reason my own touch herby
but this or that become powerpointjes  the
corner
so with her use to play this game
konami tennis it was the first went den
heijkant with my computer and he
absolutly live this at lead putin
the cartridge at some point and then the
computer silent brother up
range grandi  s console screen in
kloetinge book with something how to write
my first hello world and my loved it
from that moment om
dennis this one playing games anymore
hai just program tame sex basic en
dat was basically en mr wendy's
movies for the leaves to nice  breakfast
club rocky for anyone know which was
before and nest with ben you he wast and
with this time god and you wil keep
online now very well
my 10th those five who judge as one
Plakkie 1951
like that why didn't know have
time and  he was what i do on
programming
that is possible on ramsden here ninety-six
diorshow
and is motor milieu their bezirk en voor
throne in kobell
and he will was there doing great frink's and
briefing there was a boos and unicorns and
he whistled b-circuit  the best coach ever
with the marco big the harder what
this was to maintain
lidl detail we went to was ten years old
and one he was a pipe spaghetti
coat running and parent lee the storm was
all that a guy it before he wa  s
born
and it's funny watch your sled who then
spins spaghetti go-between join
projects where different his white and
cooks spaghetti and his bit
particular
apparently in such a way sled des silent
have a site and already spot in the d
someone's are the goto statement is
concert harmful how that was
yes luxery the evil dijkstra
here cigars from my hometown rotterdam
kool rotterdam
here set the everyone i ii at forget the
struct shirts program so that came up
the late sixties week i got struct  the
programming with basically introduced
the f statement
it in the title oops
and functions and everything was rainbow
his unicorns him well apparently week
it quiet in taste I as leed edison
got object-oriented programming and
their post basically the time those words
that ostensibly or discharged  so a you guys
has a matter but there were better
things like classes are inherent and
are polymorphism that was what
love people focused on in her stil
focus  ing om my wie talk about a oh the
company went through wheelie important part
of that is encapsulation
but then you are how adam's interpreter
who also mentions
and haircut asian ass be imported picas
with the cram encapsulation
week and achieve high cohesion and lo
link  both and baptize with the system we de
tray clausus where supposedly all of
these glasses left their own hi cohesion
maybe even der single
oils single responsibility' for om the
single of our multi-pattern and who
header love life is calling graders can
a graders the  issue was that if i
took one of these classes and modify the
the little bit runs
who brooks received samwell's will
apparently they wouldn't be your haiko
shift here
can will the maize would have been able to
break thumping somewhere else easily
wright and who basically  tried to gather
brood is at
bright england of test so there was the
boy tests and all the teams that came up
what who 'cause it white oh was a captcha
december 2nd  tab weather procedural cold
other de gryce also object orientation
so weaver steel riding spaghetti koot and
bie silent reload or clutch week
as if all the tights that 's class
they could ride each other like the early
nineties week at
component driven development and who
basically image so a system that image
components wit classes in dem he tweet
right to be cohesive where you have a
componence at the parent lee how you can
silent in taste i as round mr two
thousand who god webservices and service
oriented architecture
runs de en tire  software development
community group and growing group and he
can still remember that everyone was
extremely enthusiastic about
service de oriented architecture pica's
finally week designer system in a way
that they are truly loosely couples
asia and lot of people smiling
driving them all agree
whitney  also the craze of double you cf
how s work with double you cf almost
everyone who likes then again cf
monia handful n  og de oeien cf het web
services broadus openxml nexus die and
every one love
communicate with each other
right now be no better but remember
webservices en dan uw cf en everything
was in the time that we'd in  no way be
better safe ride to go back in time
right back to mine td5 en does my
scarf prone then get en soow is
popular again and the rest went beacause in
dutch so wie is an essay the bad and
the way
at the same time  that were trying to integrate
software allard
link and cohesion and architectural
issues that was something going on at the
same time there were people that is
train had systems
haydee is train too soft systems
integration
zodus was basically the rise of the
enterprise service bus met b  stalk
he bm websphere headset window and
dough edges solution in these webservices
en in excel en access the wine red day
well communicate with each other and
dood development world probably wat wel
hoe j  e have service oriented
architecture web service
he will like the word servers so jack and
who runs so about architectural
problems with web services and excel en
access the and even if i didn't fit who
joins fit there was another guy grady
boots
but you here  was b-circuit the father of
young man who was very enthusiastic
about
en zo wjz is the best since punt card
jury of be obtained beds lover
my door win-win de lidl sarcasm what
because i said lord roberts indiana with
what who this was who  you have basily so
a picture and with web services offers
poole teff your finger horse so well
communicate kross process maurice
is running and who her web services king
web services with whom int reviews to praise
latency walnut actually solving
the real problem
and zoë was already like that  classify too late
home reviews
where you can images webservice sorry
service
even basically joeri use and every where
everyone
always use the example of
if you wanna know wat will us postal
code is you can images web service in
looking up and i basically stops there
by being reusable picasa haven't seen
all other al direct sampras de app basic
reworked eyes think that so w-was way
more about boundaries how you turn
inside looking for and  car selection and
he check that s oh one might be you caught
me scratching
they were just too small that's why
would be modified shaky as week
breaking after class and mee those services is
the right whale with media web services is
one that knows it  preferably for the
development world actually it's the
component
or low and who invented microsoft sister and
me and everyone was very enthusiastic
about me microsoft is first and foremost
week atreden of all these
price lucas ik was een de coat
it was the xml de sucks and  now we have
rice and jason and who him swiggers
savior client and so marge gather
together again busier and containers on
via sled
bruna lev microsoft is calling micro
service to put anybody do it
the s  ame way as we've done at all along
we threw lobry images distribute
it men lief and wie justin te reviews
too late more latency
eventually sing that everyone who box
microsoft so that it room and just say
that if you have microsoft is this kool
microsoft  sister and
in just go zone nannes probably not the
best went as less as also set if you
can't image a man the elevator what mitchell
thinks that microsoft caesar die anser and
the great question is us stack overflow
the die folder that people in the  couple of
times this week
there was a user just like him have this
market or system de ride image according
to in microsofts architecture and well
we have a single user door single
request and high end up with perky woman
are t tipi requests
who already feel that  probably is in the
coating wright and he hope resistance
see you petter
wie continious lee hef link and he
thinks technology is it us with
it that technology can help me
define this candy define dutch ri  ght minutes be
able to use some free if there
is something english with whom do that for whom
and before i look at what might help
and live that bank
sam op de mid sun microsoft says it's
basically questions then get truth
also te people
would  week after being wet everyone that
this way and everyone is doing it room
and just saying design questions de rang
get
seems affliction somers beds now
because of
abc' and he turns out it shell and some of
them one thing he won't be talking about
is  the ex number of lines of sells
right we all know by now then my grow
service point about lines of code
we are builds xml and jason right here
you can see the difference is over very
very simple document and he wants i don't
get my  maintenance is so hot is so march
were den om the left site people's
first lesson for boos en het mori de bol
with ex ml the wheel great features white
like access the week route verify
has the xml that we came up with was
the who for whom  are the  tucson monells
became expat and xquery where i search
for detail insight large xml blobs
again texas ultimate reboot transform the
ex ml into something gels mee that of
aids tml and the spinning funny de jason
these days jets them all those features the
hexml all that hate
ride with red and speak client to all
those tools week after able to generate
schema's and he then hotels or je slim
jason can be called of your building
websites if you're doing javascript
some react
it's great way to communicate offers who
he do know what  ever de back-end or
other components using jason right
across who you have this relational
database and we hit relational means
now and water bottle from expo sardam a
models to the outside world zoey version
and map close to date a trends for
object ben wim  app box
addressed models de viewmodel to jason and then
finally be done elevates and map many more
lucas
in the browser i can use jason segel this
cover do you have this
we in du  s a trie improver
architectures and right
a nifty thing he or to hear is that
white jason
permits summer cheesy you he can now
ate and the belt had to of from my jason
white wood and briefing breaking bad ass
part of the series wiser
height and very early  start now hexml
serio he would pro league in a support
at aan je dream 3 member at
he do o who can be last the bio cf
that did to contract very serious er
support that now we've the new too soft
jason more serious or any  other serio wiser
and they provide
the functional title iproperty his belt
property's then
easily achieve this backwards
compatibilty where you that your services
or things or whatever your building
stil accept the jason that's coming in
both dazzling trial your heart attacks
and right and all that stuff sharpie  see
why is het zo bed to specifically channel
the service
it is because you're waiting for other
het other services der detail
bouer basically tied to the king jr
depend en tembea  afterwords and kanye
west set third pantyhose make slaves of
was a special sweetie she de penzion de
pen de sie jetzt centers she you basically
loser ton emmy time and all neck samurai
it so bed took all other services and
manage en dat you go to and liquor  store
in your be by some delicacy do know
how it's about Heerlen bed
bf signs in the netherlands everywhere
that you don't get to buy cigarettes
and nice a theory a 10 years old
wright
zo if you buying nice and you wanna
p for the nice
set it to the person behind the counter right and you why choose to pay real money for whatever reason bad it's your decision but then you do it promo
library money or credit cards from
your wallet
and then you give it to the person
behind the counter
right and you why choose to pay
neat on which the movie with 1000
do you want m nice for in be cause i handled
over is wallet and that copy help and
app 300 angry men
they the cart around fire luckly in the editor
and that is
brief you cant about you  r business dating
you're no longer for this ati over your
or you no longer everforge over your own
deta
i as others they start making
decisions based on what was to
do this guys are you they tons mi
and there is no proper en car selection
and their salad on the pendants is what
voordek simple in major
that you 400 microsoft sister and that man
of them can call you and reed reef
daten jungsheft' know why there who actually
koppie
incorrect deta bij het now know which
way is dervish reach your  data and
invoices could be calculated by some
other service payments might be
processed where you can ride all the services
customers might be preferred week
as if deta that you won't and give away
to some monells we what has that
guy on the barrel him will here
sponges dogs and humor is everyone just
can create detail you end up with an
architecture that people who caught like
this right of you slept pc headsets place
at it who couldn't query your database
is within  the harpy sea
something like that would often de cedar arby's i
is bert everywhere
right on just saying that you interview
so had from latency
and people take away
your data and the steel image
drink schooling [ __ ] schooling sphinx en
der ze live link
white arby's ie zo crossing in  process
by dries thousand branch in link
a copy them so building webservices
having them colt keep of process and
sharing detail long john der Spoel 3
quite being giving what we also
save deployment to you under website
for such a company that he raises the bar to do
how the dark and he do hotels they
set it so thick and to achieve
operational guilty
discreet everyone wants to be yet your
with the visor then this fold 300
microsoft sister
den apparently want men member time there
special if they all therefore has storage
technology and  he invites if your system
is there award wider it might be your
heart that fold the entire caught and
that you with microsoft sister and maybe
docker container  you can take one down
and replace it easily by another
met je als heft weer in member that if
you read write this service no matter
how small of bic it is he it still it
total rear right and totally rights
usually comes buks ik als de ding  that
was already there was on the most
words were soft etcetera etcetera and wie
intro djoez' blood bikes
picas wie her link everywhere you
know who love minecraft server is the
operations department
the closet na odf te de plicate maintain and
infrastructure and won it there about  300
services instead of one big men left
right there probably not very happy you
build it dokker is also great dokker is
absolutely great for deployment right
because it isolates and it skills very
well it's multi cloud will you can basiq
scar dokker container om him the sun
dokker container over to measure and just works
great weather jet
your license plate dokker
container over from your own developing
machine de folds to production and
what works online  e maybe now also
works on production are that's really
great
lf there he drank get in which proving
what wat dokker containers in plow over
the folds mens using dokker
indefinitely improve encapsulation and
isolation of your process
so dokker is certainly great tool fact
that he drank get
keep it souls clutch of my entire
system at real time
he went silent there long clutch and
a land of the pen and cissé and spraying
the lidl dokker
magic about this 1000 willy help
2002 die improve the architecture so
led be of look have what probably or
what might help
wright and aan talking about systems that
a more complex not a free system used
walnut and free system user services
mond and free system uses
bulge what but it got talking about
distribute the systems therefore complex
and who didn't give him a toe
for meditation  years maybe dear longer
howie can achieve this hike regional also
coupling a box kan of systems and
probably you seen the caps at a o  ude
done trying to explain is still
technology is axel the people sitting
here with who is not the star sign step
work and look and it was so true en
zoë was trying to bring as basically
the foundry his encapsulation when you
listen to the business stakeholders  by
the de business owners or ever be used to
have learned wine so far that we should
look at the name are the words right and
who and day manages customer product
order and deeply colmar entities and
then we'll also adwords like a customer
orders the product  or an order was
shipped to the customer or a customer
riziv de discounts and everytime
we look at these words
but usually architects
they look at the bigger picture
and
he  eft products' en judgements and several
prices for products'
maybe even discount for customer media
have shipping status for norther
et cetera et cetera andy's attributes
wie put them in site a single entity
hoor wie put them very very close
together and my passion is to dx
limits be disclosed go do and
not be in so a transaction orders its
consistency treatment let's have
succeed the neck simply
for I simple discount and product info
does a wheelie not to be together
but I do dc so there is a consistency
requirements and which probably
frame the requirements differently to
figure out of date if they belong
together for example this is in for
customer
rups in of customer discount is higher
than 12 percent
customers can mediate it order purple products'
ipad's diggler swan button on
the one could be has the  coast number is
and fullname is longer than twenty
characters week and on get a discount at
the public customers and loo  king at you
hi there i get right and that's when
you're actually under rights pull the
closet we you're looking for things the
don't share so its hi consistency
world shutter
time the week and promo be separated en
zo die is de  discount and the product info
the year problem had relay de the devonian
share so a consistency and they have
requirements to be modified
wit in so a transaction back to the
your de let's have
also at another example prize and
discount
show they go together like every frame
weer  in a requirement even product
there is a ceo
de Kuste me mine button geddes regular
customer discount
and the business the might say of course
den dijk promotes lead to share so
inconsistency treatment and did not do
the go together now the free sign look
at this order
entity  that who the before at the who
might end up with where we lift
customer and we take the first take
the last take
am now product btec the take
a the description
with settings  and or drawing hey customer
status and a product discount
and pudding the next two things that they
do the room called bammin something
hells hike
it only the pen without business what this
thing is calfguide oh no hate and besides
that taking
vinckx this early jump wilde
well vinkt de kas den restart
showing all other stuff about the sphinx
another example to be your order status
and the shipping still but i they might
also go together with the reasult that
may be
try te critical highly cohesive vinckx
nou snap wat who now
target  is make sure that bit
this silent system right even wie die
couple everything from each other and
don't share
anything then i of it is joepie
castricum builder system zo
weekend aires together using identifiers
en wie basically den en dag win
customer identifier where customer take
and  she kissed my identifier and read about
here whoever customer discount despite
tough kissed me you are yours that lyps
about der and who heav  and order
specific customer
and it will be so brown to this Kustom
identifier well who don't share business
dating and not
who oil share the customer identifier
en robin doing this for quite a while
all that the bed briefing king box for
choose
icann icann  everyone knows silver angry
scandic keith
arntz the worst thing ever they might
actually be giving the calls otherwise i
couldn't
connekt deta van wit in her database
it basically changes how the
traditional think about domain en
entities drives
finding the attributes and  putting them
in the correct
solo is a premium harting it takes time
which his own words can be an issue
if you have land of developers dat c is
architect huis bent busy for like two
weeks
when can you start doing some
development bij het
and then the  architects s while the archi
ects taking decisions and very sorry
het weer taking decisions towards the r
ght direction wide
k was wi images system dit spray
t  he u
to say the least just behind building to
earth
who find out that way to do wrong
direction
and who does not earn the work beagles
turning back least rebuilding the system
it starts so dead prima turley playing
with technology
lucas that will mean that will end  up
with spaghetti cold it was wie hef die
smiley cohesive in forsyth
insight and consistency job3 glasses and
that whitney saarloos there actually thinks
it also to each other that much
anymore
something new question of can this file
also all the other side of the dome
cover  is not for sale each other again
and who can come lens ilosab componence
or even build with contact your
family you we die die die you he
load come with building with contacts
who idea for workshop about this top me
then the last to date en  he and the
president there
both motionless the promised blue book
ladder them heavy reads how he they watch
the blue book a theory jent
lotso way and heavy mind and
there [ __ ]  s recently give an interview
after ten years of the blue book and the
set in my mother for
heft it do it granny he be
biased probably most of it and
focused much more conversion and the context
je king cole the construction it could have sex on
usually  called en services we der
logical services
white edition 2 leaguer keep u takes
and lucy as we did 1000 times
communicate les
picas white coat bieling with prices and
discounts
not the talk to some other thing that
deals with customers phone number for
example
bright because who has  die smiley
cohesive inks insight consistency tree 3
might be there for system where we use te
hef layers called the business layer the
date a layer the user interface
pray every single layer was a
responsible for all and teeth and now be
done have so layers and the  more with whom
stil builder system with mina have already
they pick logical services and that
omen develop services and look at
one of them then will see that the three
layers comeback insight won of the
services oh oh man insight won of the
pillars of
size lucas no matter what it's not like
what would it be separated box insight
coat time with whom you always have you
send face fusion orbe user
has the user interface is not  for and and
to be used are ep hi who problem yes
always hef detail and detail there a
date a babies bright it well a single
boring loree single services responsible
for everything something like that responsible maybe
for minecraft servers so insider fat
my reviews mike rovio los but me  want
controllers and so on and salon and on
wow in the database so if they don't
share daytime om each other keep
at the indiana minutes image this user
interface who do that via compa
city life
and this is a live sex ampel of het
and  application you can see is
divided by lover small parts
but i only the mycroft fuse you want
der sman views
wear for example one of those service
provider
wie already die mln de deta for the part
of the screen and maybe de customer
service and maybe de shipping services
drinks measurement record share
de jan provine parts of the screen such a
v-sign real-world examples for ik such a
pot december sometimes circle
at it and who break it down  then who
does have that spice become john-paul
coming from the product catalog service
and all for parts like the price for me
pricing servers and then
boomers harry csfr door have in in the
names and vis is enter
hai just made them up with this is  how
you can read compo's de user interface
agent from all of the show they don't
heft de communicate de en oma michelle
hier van de micro views dan het heft de
communicate with each other time one last
went so whose functions classers
componence things  my processus
right arm always christening myself what
the next went and he yesterday someone
certhia the micro service between arm
already the grinding om the height ring
light so
admiration what's the next big thing he
lets gentlemen  preserving
functions and its service at azure
services for example both hash function
school in function and schooling functions
put out of process and hopefully you be
seeing that the constant lee called eating
caught here is the turn calling widely
et technology are architectural styles
an iron our health
it could be
a creation the words called the king
called at desso great book written by
someone were taking fat ass and those
that set
who is not in version of communication for
business events and who is not a
supplement and service oriented
architecture with an event  driven
architecture sorry focus on this event
driven ederim moment die services die
saarloos den haag am talking about db
circuit kennel kali charlie closet and who
you have so a mole problem and pure
can write
it somehow but half am not too keepin
think so that is for  example we have
an order and order lives in salo a
white who is not the ship the teams
the flower to the order who is not the ch  ips
and then this anders zijn loon nothing to
know when the order is complete orf in
is door accepte door paid or never'
en voor that we use events' en please
subscribe button down sharing business
daten that means that i've en sarlini small
white
arno know if there and small is de mal
en in valkenburg han solo definitely a
thousand fit
yes da is that i don't
bubble is an event' that content die
order shipping address
this rudder ass agree and that guy order
accepted with just one ear turn  die so
te poe dit morgan gigi
the service om de left can say the or or
publish and die guy order eksept it and
it ives om die had site without
sharing business deta and it can say the
order is accepted
arno that he didn't get the invoice
die  hearer and he drank no need
product and he do heads product in
stock range do kill price and he
do about mannequin discount and if
not do my work is an event and
message
because right now or dry the right know the opportunities
where yo  utube communicate address of no
one is going to use at it
where you have to coding
it prices and invoices don't add
detail from another service that deals
with customers phone number for dick
simple in just thousand and the reason sbk
cri service is the technical report  i
for the specific business capability
and they feel became and briefing insight
this service and they are able to their
work without sharing an idea to
have argued motor drugs have it something
about look took the service in
as if apps that run on drugs have that those  vent
possibly
wie however invoiced the order to price
en het some point het coetzee de order
was peet in an event which can just the
or dry die
en de swing om de bones might say hey
yes see die ordres peet now why can
finally ship it we  tie download
product names he download product
price to tony holt interested in one
i'm interested in
is knowing the week and the size of the
product i can't grab chat
to he nie  t the ship it
in containers see you the circle is now
complete
i already do such also the shipping address
and highly you for the i-th technical
somewhat formative for the business
capability of shipping substance but it had
just set one more
aldo a  other country and then a one could
be under left side the service the site and
kissed me quick' a letter word
at the motionless wyatt decided that may
be cheese die earnshaw's enough money
maybe then your customers for this
pacific time maybe they did something  as
a then it is a you whether to
the right side the wright site so it
well how do the customer preferred or
why the customer the game preferred at the
death note that the least ship
vaster on prowein chip fixed shipping
options want it  nothing the
package on the check slicer
bright and death ds because it again the
technical in stock i for this
business capability
en wie and dat whynot sharing and the
business detail
we it he said the
wiesje probabl  y of week all the services
after which i green from en
english talked about service oriented
architecture and how it was all about
these job three sentences built
encapsulation as yo win minute
insight visual studio it might
look like things is a logical service
white
threesome cobouw  this weekend rolland de of
stuff
the service itself is still the technical
caught the go into his studio at the
in death do raise a ladder stuff like
mike rogue use my croque controls
etcetera etcetera en box
congo in to visual studio light will end
up with love  it show my services and
insight they show my services who
has components that process events'
we it such a logical service can be a
bit bigger
bright we die smaller componence de
procession fans join a learn
through work and then immediately paulus
new fans  box would probably be the
micro service is johan how how they can
be colt microsoft
lets are of lucca them so that we
can see  how small they might be calm
zo haven project here and so little
there bit discovery
this is sam excisting democrat to more
or less dembo
feel solution zo it contains some detail
ass agree controller zz there it centers
he urged focus discovered at it
if you want to know what it looks like
in the coil form
al provider link it who drives them to the interpreter
to make sure that you can get more info
and also the coat to get up for this
repositories zoey seen this triangle
where sales starts and it  its for
drugs you already have it drill into a single
händler this is the submit order händler
this is the co this is not free sometimes
or cold with it's basically in expats a
message with an detail en het
en het just go asked the methods to
collect  such products ideal and then
it stores him
insight sam and the framework finn en
het save changes to the database met het
al zo et des de product eyes to this
new message
bright wie hef de or dry die de Kusten
marley en wie hef  product met products'
is in view lookup here
nothing more than a list of aires
zo in free check out orders the means
de vent
these are interior and interior and a
list of vintage
arno choeur tv shows in te josh this is
just for demo purposes  met alle duits is
publish or the submitted and anyone
interested can access this message and
subscribe for example
wie f finance
en do you want händler here and this is
the orders het mid tot händler
zo is accept this message can and what these
fingers  is recognize apparently
something interesting in the details something like that
stores the detail insided such a database
and then it sense a new messaging in
ecpm a process your soul and he don't get
more actions to get i was he one
dystopia smal is possible
but it  weather he clocks about business
capabilities and technical for it's
a that wie herbie's cohesive inks he
will so because the single responsibility'
principle and smart 6 fits in site
my handlers so to you navgate de
prepayment process command and it is in
site so a
technical service and gentlemen 6 process the
payment and it comes out to his third
party epa
you make sure that everything works
and that publish
whole payment is also see it so arnoud
talked about finance and the  bout sales
and all day finsh earring
identifier well week and harbor succeed
chipping
and the house another händler and that he average
chair handler's
orders and payments i see
it this thing she does something at
the date a dead it will be the order was
it  in the middle
this went was pm and succeed and now once
the judgment is in the middle tent the payment
instruction that this can continue
so maybe this week's for above messages
and that's and salt another knife arts
media team that picks the ribbon up the
shipment iron ore
de  this is basically keeps small of
coach you the hef and hoist malden dating
you have to michelle or how small dave and then
looked over the details his
melted mother the pen sun in the morning
cup to  big you vinken
cause if you used i inter chair wood
am the database with never mind blowing
capping that you see that billion eking
small steps
bright and you can basically call box
microsoft they you want to when it's
more clare hopefully
that wie can make this  work by just
sharing he identifiers
het zo to summarize eijsink microsoft
sizzling temt mais on people to reclaim
de core meaning of service oriented
architecture
running they try to get up get back to
those boundaries and find out if i can
heft is en cap solution that we  've been
wanting
since object orientation we've been
looking the public chips cry to make
sure that our services can somehow stay
in think of the entire process as that
have a in its system time again trying
to minimize the je link and tryin to
greece  the autonomy
for services can
were service is the
technical for the specific business buy
multi on which you he hyuh cohesion and lo
link
bright eyes [ __ ] mi  crosoft is is just so
know then runs and he caught that's how i
create
concrete my services that don't share
dating
with it he helps you nuts are this the
small pull on leash do the micro have
the power microsofts in it self how you
find t  services can share detail
if you wanna know more about this there
is a lot more to learn for example
how die de hand that de cio's de comp'ny
year for here
regular regular few times their english
at avans so you have to systems design
die  so the training where ran talks for
5 days about this stuff wie jansen he the
workshop that whoever does this yesterday and the
day before for to date and who is
more adler could have it fransen both
already so
then start writing down this url you can
get  free from the city cap des journaux
this once stood the previous url the
preview l was for this the us that
training day to the de handy we
already have such a video is much better to go der
in person
review because the videos you can watch some
vi  deo's using the previews die url
if you go to this you elsewhere much more
information and that longer you model is
already zo onder
zo and dennis van de stilt and it's
barry visible with frank's for watching
may go pro tour under a versions there is a
slides
questions
[Applause]